today we're talking about google i o
announcements applied to mel summit and
cloud sql maintenance i'm anew and
welcome to this week in cloud where we
serve you the lowest latency news
we're still basking in the after glow of
google i o and did you know that there
were tons of cloud announcements
head to the blog for a list of keynotes
topics and links to on-demand sessions
there's everything from machine learning
to cloud run jobs and even how to
increase your productivity with google
workspace
at google cloud we've helped thousands
of companies accelerate their ai efforts
empower their data scientists and extend
the ability to build ai-driven apps and
workflows to more people this includes
everyone no data science or machine
learning background required
so please join us june 9th for the
google cloud applied ml summit a digital
event which will bring together some of
the world's leading ml and data science
professionals all to explore the latest
cutting edge ai tools for developing
deploying and managing machine learning
models at scale register today
cloud sql has now made self-service
maintenance generally available this
allows you the freedom to upgrade your
cloud sql instances maintenance version
to the latest version the benefit is
that you can receive the latest security
patches bug fixes and new features on
demand when combined with denying
maintenance periods self-service
maintenance gives you the flexibility to
upgrade your instance according to your
own maintenance schedule
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud
you